this brings me to my third example of
divination in the early Christian period
and this example is an actual early
Christian divination book that we have
here at Harvard it dates likely from the
5th of the 6th century this book is very
very tiny it measures less than 3 inches
in height and in width it could have fit
in the palm of someone's hand it's made
of vellum it's been tested and it was
sheepskin that was used and the writing
on it is in very fine unseals a fine
handwriting that kind of imitates the
handwriting that would have been used
for biblical text it's a text that in
its very paleography in the very script
that it uses claims a kind of authority
for itself a sophisticated style of
writing the text is titled the gospel of
the lots of Mary and within it it
contains multiple Oracle's we're not
really sure how it would have been used
to tell you the truth what's clear is
that someone held it in their hand and
if you look closely at the text you can
see that it's been well summed the
middle of each page is dark with the
stains of sweat and dirt from a ritual
expert who would have held it and
thumbed through the pages trying to find
an answer to the petitioners questions
we can imagine the possibility that a
petitioner in the 6th century or in the
6th century in Egypt because the text
was written in Coptic the common
language in Egypt at that time but the
petitioner would have come to the ritual
expert who would have held a text like
this and his or her hands and leapt
through it to find an answer to the
petitioners troubles it's a practice not
unlike that that we found at crema
although at crema was a public practice
in a public square of throwing the
Ostrogoth and trying to find an answer
from the God in this case we have a
practice with a small book a kind of
Biblio mansi where a given page would
tell you the answer to the question that
you held in your heart and that you
discussed with the ritual expert about
your future let me read you the incipit
or the introduction of the text
so that you can have a sense of the
concerns that an early Christian might
have brought to a ritual expert the
gospel of the lots of Mary the mother of
the Lord Jesus Christ she to whom
Gabriel the Archangel brought the good
news he who will go forward with his
whole heart will obtain what he seeks
only do not be of two minds the
handwriting that looks like a biblical
script the reference to Mary the mother
of Jesus Christ
these give a kind of authority to the
text a kind of religious sanction to it
the first oracle reads this way o human
with their tongues they love you greatly
but their heart is far from you and you
know what happened to you before today
that you almost lost your life in any
case they certainly lie and wait for you
the Oracles in this small little
divination device often talk about not
fearing about trusting in God they give
pieces of divine advice for the fifth or
the sixth century Egyptian Christian who
came to the ritual expert seeking some
understanding of what might happen in
his or her future seeking some guidance
in his or her path for the present